any worse Sheen was a prolific actor on
the small screen which made her death at
the age of 45 all the more tragic this
is the devastating story of the 24
actors untimely passing any worshing
best known for her appearances in Bosch
the rookie and 24 died of cancer on
January 29 2023. the actor was 45
following her passing worship's husband
Stephen Full a fellow actor issued a
heartfelt statement that read There is a
cavernous hole in the soul of this
family today but she left us the tools
to fill it she found Wonder in the
simplest moment she didn't require music
to dance she taught us not to wait for
adventure to find you go find it it's
everywhere and find it we shall any
worshing was born in St Louis Missouri
for IMDb her first major role was in a
2002 episode of Star Trek Enterprise
after a series of guest appearances and
projects such as Frasier and
Supernatural she landed a recurring role
in the Everlasting General Hospital
general hospital was a big one for me
because it was the first time that I was
like on TV really regularly for Big
Break however came in 10 2009 when she
nabbed the role of Renee Walker in the
action Series 24. in a retrospective
interview with pop culture principal
wershing expressed gratitude for
appearing in the Kiefer sutherland-led
series telling the outlet again I was
such a huge fan of the show and
sometimes I just say wow I was a part of
that show and that's pretty amazing her
starring role in 24 opened the
floodgates of the small screen Landing
her guest appearances in CSI NCIS and a
small Arc in TNT's Dallas 2013 proved to
be a major year for washing she starred
alongside Troy Baker in The Last of Us
the PlayStation 3 video game which was
recently adapted into a series by HBO
her character in the nine episode drama
is portrayed by actress Anna tour
following her The Last of Us appearance
where she joined Bosch as Julia Brasher
she would later go on to appear in
Marvel's runaways and Nathan Fillion's
the rookie is Rosalind one of wershing's
final role saw her appear as the iconic
org Queen in Star Trek Picard it's
somewhat Bittersweet that one of
warsheen's final roles was within a
franchise that featured her first major
gig this wasn't lost to the actor who
jokingly suggested in an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter that both her
Picard and Enterprise characters were
connected she told the outlet it is Star
Trek we can make anything happen several
of Annie worshing's collaborators took
to social media to pay tribute to the
friend and colleague The Vampire Diaries
showrunner Julie pleck took to Twitter
to open up about how she was a fan of
war machines thanks to her stint on 24
where Shane appeared in the CW Series as
the recurring Lily Salvatore The Last of
Us video game co-creator and co-writer
Neil druckman also wrote on Twitter just
found out my dear friend Annie wershing
passed away we just lost a beautiful
artist and human being my heart is
shattered appearing as the fan favorite
test and one of the most popular games
of all time is just one of the actors
notable highlights worship's Timeless
co-star Abigail Spencer took to
Instagram to grieve over her colleague's
passing calling the late actress the
best scene partner in an emotional post
black druckman and Spencer along with
several other colleagues and fans had
begun sharing a GoFundMe page dedicated
to supporting wershing's family the
fundraiser describes washing as a
private person who wanted to live her
life on her terms and be with her family
since her career in television kicked
off in 2002 where she lent her talents
to several fandoms and IPS emerging as a
truly versatile actor who could take on
any role with the actor now gone it's
quite beautiful to see members from
drastically different fandoms such as
Star Trek 24 The Last of Us and many
many more coming together to pay tribute
to her
[Music]